the fight for the white house kicking
into high gear
joe biden finding himself in some hot
water after these comments suggesting
that the latino community
is more diverse than the
african-american community take a listen
unlike the african-american community
with notable exceptions the latino
community is an incredibly diverse
community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
you go to florida you find a very
different attitude about immigration
in certain places than you do when
you're in arizona
so it's a very different a very diverse
community
sir president trump hitting biden
claiming that he's quote
no longer worthy of the black vote the
former vice president then clarifying
his comments on twitter
saying in part and here i quote in no
way did i mean to suggest the
african-american community is a monolith
not by identity not on issues not at all
end quote so will biden stumble give
trump's campaign
new momentum the latest real clear
politics average shows the race is
tightening
greg i i thought i'd start with you
welcome back do you think that this gaff
uh that this gap is going to attract
any more votes to uh president trump
other than let's say kanye west
um well you know what why gaffs are
great when they tell the truth
and uh joe biden spoke the party's truth
they see blacks as a homogenous entity
it's why they mock and marginalize
people like you just did with kanye west
anybody who's outside the box kanye west
candace owen thomas soul you name it
if you don't fit into the democrats
assumption of what a black person should
be
and what joe biden decides who a black
person should be because you remember it
was just a few uh maybe a month ago he
decided he was the one who decided who
was black and who wasn't
the fact is the dems just assumed they
don't have to do squat for blacks
because they got him in the back pocket
meanwhile donald trump is actively
competing for those votes
you know he tried to get the lowest
unemployment in modern history he helped
out historical black colleges
he went for prison reform he shows that
he's got
he believes in compete in competing for
that vote
also the difference between republicans
and democrats republicans
never denied trump's flaws they they
knew that he could be crude rude and
even offensive but the democrats
they're in full denial of a substantial
structural flaw
their candidate may be losing his mind
and it's not even that it's not
funny it's kind of sad because you know
it would it'd be okay if you could laugh
about it
but this guy he's not going to be the
nominee juan and you know it
it's he's going to be gone before
november
ain't gonna happen you say biden wait
biden's gonna be gone
yes i predict that's why they haven't
had the vp they haven't
selected the vp yet because you can't
select the vp until you have the p
and if you select the vp what is the vp
what if the vp
should be p like what if you select
kamala harris but she should be the p
so you can't pick her for vp that's the
that's the theory i'm sticking to it
okay
all right all right i hear you loud and
clear uh kennedy what do you make of
this
so-called gaff it looks like it's
getting more attention to pick up on
greg's point
it's getting more attention on the right
than it is on the left and even among
black people
uh what a surprise that uh this race is
being covered with uh partiality and
imbalance that's very shocking to me
and i'm i'm so relieved that the race
war is now three-dimensional good job
joe
i think it's really important to pit
latino voters
against african-american voters that was
really really important
and i hope every single voter regardless
of race
or party or geographic location i hope
they look at both candidates both of the
mainstream candidates very skeptically
and remember that joe biden was the one
who
talked up his relationship with
segregationists
he was the one who authored bills with
strom thurmond when they were both on
the senate judiciary committee
he was a ranking member while strom
thurman was a chairman
and they authored that 1986 anti-drug
abuse bill
that created those sentencing
disparities that put an entire
generation
of black men in prison because they got
a lot more time
for doing crack than white offenders did
for doing cocaine which essentially
it's the exact same drug he also
authored the 1994
crime bill but it wasn't just strom
thurman james eastland there were other
members of the senate
who were avowed segregationists and
joe biden talked up his relationship
with all of them
he's got a lot of problems and that's
why charlemagne the god
really took a harsher tone with joe
biden than
many other favorable leftists have in
media because he wants some answers to
those questions
and that's when joe biden made another
gap that greg was talking about when he
said
if you vote for trump you ain't black
that is incredibly offensive
and it is toxic pandering that is
totally unnecessary
given where we are at this point in our
modern political history
trey gowdy another dust up on the
campaign trail yesterday with trump
saying biden
is out to hurt god so i i come to you
because
you know politics inside and out is this
intended to help the president
with the evangelical base who who is he
playing
to here i don't know why because i
i don't i'm not a theologian but i'm not
sure you can hurt god and i think with
the pga and the nba starting i'm not
even sure god's following politics
right now i think what republicans ought
to be talking about
what republicans ought to be talking
about is contrasting
all of the aspects of the american
family and whether you're better off
the last four years than you were under
biden obama
and to kennedy's point i mean it's
always been a challenge
to understand what joe biden said now
you add the variable of what did he mean
even if he has a moment of lucidity and
you understand exactly what he
said he is a recidivist when it comes to
saying racially curious thing remember
what he said juan about
about president obama that he's the
first mainstream candidate
that is clean and articulate i mean what
what does that mean he says you're not
black if you're not going to vote
for him well that's news to tim scott
he's been black his entire life
so he's a career offender as it relates
to racially curious comments this is
just the latest one
okay so dana the the real clear politics
average
has now uh vice i'm sorry yeah former
vice president biden leading by 6.4
points a month ago
it was nine points so it's it's
tightened a little bit
uh you know 538 has a seven
point margin but anyway the point is
bill steffen the new campaign manager
for president trump
says he thinks this tightening is as a
result of the
president holding briefings again what
do you think
well first i would like to uh welcome
trey gowdy to the five i mean that was
um a
fantastic debut of a segment um
i think a couple of things one remember
i've said from the beginning that
as we get closer to fall it is going to
tighten up and
guess what we are closer to fall so it's
tightening up because people start
paying a little bit more attention
and the other thing is that the trump
campaign had maintained that during the
coronavirus
it was difficult for them to pay a lot
of attention to defining joe biden
they're trying to figure out what would
work
and i think they've alighted upon the
thing that is working best
which is to suggest that he would be
pull this bait and switch
when it comes to saying that he would be
very moderate but actually be
very progressive and as the trump
campaigns as a tool
for the left i do want to mention
something on timing though and if the
trump campaign wants these numbers to
tighten even more
i think they should think about
something like this yesterday when joe
biden said those comments
that he then apologized for and then he
in a video and then he tweeted about
because he's having to clean it up
i think the best thing if you're the
trump campaign if you're the president
stand back don't just let let the media
cover
that story for the day when the
president suggested that joe biden
did not have religion that he didn't
believe in his faith
and then he wanted to hurt god
immediately that's a story so
you everyone's going to go and cover
that as well the joe biden comments
about his thinking about blacks and how
they think
would have been the main story today so
i would just say that if they want those
numbers to tighten even
make it a little closer let joe biden
have some time in the sun
free advice from dana perino for the
trump camp